DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Hello again.
I'm Dustin Kirkland, a
product manager at Google,
and I'm here with one of my
colleagues, David Oppenheimer.
He's a software engineer working
on multi-tenancy in Kubernetes
at Google.
David, I've got a couple
of questions for you
about multi-tenancy
in Kubernetes.
I was at KubeCon a
year ago in Berlin,
and multi-tenancy
was quite the topic.
What have you heard
over the last year
in terms of customer
and user demands
around multi-tenancy
in Kubernetes?
DAVID OPPENHEIMER:
Yeah, so a year ago
it was very popular for people
to just run lots of clusters
if they had different users or
applications who they wanted
to isolate from one another.
And over the last year,
we've either introduced
or brought to a greater level
of maturity, like beta or GA,
a bunch of features in
open-source Kubernetes
that enable multi-tenancy
within a cluster.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Within
a single cluster.
So that's a big change,
because I've seen this as well.
Every team, every department
gets their own Kubernetes
cluster.
They're completely
separate management planes.
So you're saying that as
of Kubernetes 1.10 now,
I should be able to run multiple
tenants in a single cluster?
DAVID OPPENHEIMER:
Yeah, that's right.
So some of the features that we
have that are mature now are--
the most well-known one
is RBAC for authorization.
So you can put very
fine-grained controls
over which users or groups
of users or applications
can create and update and delete
which API resources on the API
server.
And so that kind of gives
you control plane isolation.
And then we also
have other features
that provide isolation on the
node or at the container level.
For example, we have
pod security policy,
which lets an administrator
say, for example, no privilege
containers in this cluster
or in this namespace,
or you can't run any containers
as root in this namespace,
or these users can't do that.
So gives you pretty
fine-grained control over what
privileges a container's
running in the cluster.
And then another policy that's
kind of at the node level
is network policy,
which controls
which pods can communicate with
which other pods so that you
can, for example, isolate
namespaces from one another,
or say that you have part
of your application in one
namespace and part
of your application
in another namespace.
And the pods that
constitute that application
should be able to
talk to each other
across that namespace
boundary, but not
with other namespaces
in the cluster.
And so you can kind of
partition your cluster
based on the groups of
users and the applications
and the topology of
the application using
network policy.
So between those three features,
the RBAC and the network policy
and the pod security
policy, we've
kind of met a lot of
the needs that people
have for multi-tenancy for
running enterprises or software
as a service where you
want to provide isolation
between untrusted users
sharing a cluster.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: So now it's
realistic for Coke and Pepsi,
as separate tenants, to
run in the same cluster.
That feels reasonable
at this point.
DAVID OPPENHEIMER:
Well, so Coke and Pepsi
is kind of going to one
extreme of the spectrum.
And so one of the things that
people have asked a lot about--
and actually there's been
just very recent technology
developed around
solving that problem--
is kind of a hypervisor level
of isolation between containers.
So when I was talking about
pod security policy and network
policy earlier,
those are kind of
based on the container
isolation in Docker
or whatever runtime
you're using,
and also what your
network provider
can provide for
the network policy.
But multiple
containers on a node
are still sharing
the same kernel.
And so if you want the
level of protection
that you need, say,
for Coke and Pepsi,
then you should use
something like gVisor,
which was announced
today, or yesterday, I
guess, from Google,
which allows you
to have kind of the hypervisor
level of security and isolation
between containers that
are sharing a cluster.
And so I think that for the
Coke and Pepsi use case,
now it's available, now
it's possible to do that.
But that's a very
recent development.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: That's great.
And in terms of what's coming
next, can you give us, maybe,
a brief taste of
where multi-clusters
and multi-tenancy is
headed in Kubernetes?
DAVID OPPENHEIMER: Sure.
There's kind of two
areas where there's
ongoing work for multi-tenancy.
One of them is
related to policies,
so making it easier for people
to specify these policies.
Today you kind of have to be a
bit of an expert in Kubernetes
in order to know how to set
up the multi-tenancy policies
in a multi-tenant cluster.
So some of the work
that's going on
is kind of towards unifying and
making it simpler to specify
the different policies.
And then we also
have work that's
kind of not related to policies,
but more related to isolation.
So for example, improving
the isolation between tenants
in the control plane.
So for example, different
users can't DOS each other
by overloading the scheduler,
overloading the API server.
So giving the controllers
in the other components
of the Kubernetes
control plane some notion
of how much of the
control plane resources
each tenant is using so
that it can kind of fairly
share the resources
across those tenants,
or at least prevent them
from DOSing each other,
and ensure that all the
tenants can make progress
even if one of them is trying
to impose a lot of load
on the scheduler
or the API server,
or some other piece
of the control plane.
So that's one of the key things
that we're working on now
to improving the
multi-tenancy story.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Yeah.
It's super impressive how
far we've come in a year.
And I'm really looking forward
to where we're going next.
David, thank you.
DAVID OPPENHEIMER: Yeah,
great talking to you.
DUSTIN KIRKLAND: Yeah, thanks.